[Music]
all right let's go to rosalie
the great rosalie in san diego
california what's up rosalie
good morning how are you i'm doing well
how are you doing i i really couldn't be
doing better actually
good good what's up
um well i would like your
expert expert opinion on if i should um
[Music]
inform my siblings
of my mom's changes in her trust
oh tell me about this
okay a little background um i am the
youngest of three children
my oldest sibling um has a different
father from my
middle
sibling and i
um
my
uh dad you're wait you're the youngest
of three or oldest
youngest youngest okay
yes oh and then your next youngest
sibling the one right above you has a
different dad
no my oldest my oldest sibling has a
different day okay okay okay me and my
middle sibling have the same death okay
excellent and we all of course have the
same mom
um
my dad
uh died in 2002 our
my middle sibling and my dad died in
2002. oh man
my
dad sorry it was a hard worker and he
um built a pretty good nest egg
for him and my mom
um my dad my
dad also supported my oldest sibling you
know um
i i don't even remember how old she was
when my mom and dad got married
but
um
my dad supported her
you know with
food clothing school you know all that
stuff
um so my dad died in 2002
he
um did not have a will
but he did
put me
on one of his accounts okay his main
account he put me on but when he died
all of his assets rolled to your mom
right correct correct everything went to
my mom
um so
after
my dad died i pretty much um my mom was
old school she didn't pay bills she
didn't write checks she didn't
do taxes she my dad said sign here and
she did that was pretty much you know
old school from a long time ago
so my mom
you know did
like what my dad told her to not in a
bad way but just my dad took care of my
mom
so
um
everything rolled over to my mom
again she had
my dad incurred assets
not you know he's not a millionaire but
he did very well okay all right so bring
me to now
to now um well
the original trust was done in 2012. it
took my mom
10 years to do the trust
so in 2012 she did her original trust
um and she left
the house
to my middle sibling
and the assets the money was split
between the three of us that was her
original trust okay so approximately
2015
my mom started to
talk about changing her trust um
[Music]
i'm pretty much the one who
you know did the bills we you know we
had our routine we went grocery shopping
we did our stuff together and
my
middle sibling
would come around he
um took care of the house
maintained the house i should say you
know he didn't take care of it but he
maintained the help
um
so in about 2015 my mom started talking
about
her wanting to change
the conditions of the trust why'd she
change it
because she knew
that i was the one who was taking care
of her
um she my mom again like i said was old
school when you did something for my mom
she
felt she hadn't hooked you up back
okay so fast forward she's changed her
will and made you the person over
everything right
no okay no that
she what she changed
was that she added me to
the house okay
but left the rest pretty much the same
splitting the assets between the three
of us okay that she did
um change
um
you know the ownership of the house so
is your brother under the impression
that whenever she passes away he gets
the house scot-free
yes okay
um
why can't she tell
what this sounds like a conversation for
her to have why isn't she not doing that
well
my mom
knows her children
and she's
she
knows that if she was to say anything
that
the middle sibling would probably not
come around anymore
um she wants him to come around this was
like in
2017 is when she finally um
when she
changed her trust yeah but she wants to
have her cake and eat it too
what there's there's something here
you're not telling me is is is mom okay
does mom have no alzheimer's or
something not okay okay so in 2000 like
i said in 2017 she did the trust and she
pretty much told me you know don't
say anything and
she on her own went to the lawyer uh-huh
um i did drive her only because she
didn't drive anymore okay so the lawyer
also told me that assets were moms not
mine not my brothers yes or my sibling
correct
so she had the right to do whatever she
wanted to with her asset correct it was
it not that it wasn't none of our
business but tell me about your mom tell
me about your mom
um my mom
is um
does she have cancer does she have
alzheimer's or something
she in um
2019 my mom started showing signs of
dementia okay okay
um she
this you know at first it was little
stuff and then in late 2019 my mom
fell
she fell and she hit her head pretty
hard and so the dementia went full force
okay
so is um is she so i moved in with my
mom i moved in with her
um in 2019 i moved in permanent with her
okay
um so
fast forward to 2021
i was diagnosed diagnosed with cancer
i'm sorry um
so my doctor informed me that there was
a good chance everything would work out
good but that i needed to get my affairs
in order
so i did
contact
my mom's attorney
to let him know you know he told me you
have no right to change anything you
have no right to her trust and i told
him i understand that but i just wanted
to inform him
that i might not be in the picture
anymore
if my
cancer
progressed
so
um yeah
so hold on rosie we're like
get down to your question here
what's the yeah what can i help you with
um
so
i need to my mom always told me
not to say anything what she had done
okay it was her business and
and although i was i wasn't involved
other than taking her i got that i you
don't need to
you need you need to move past that in
your own heart and mind okay you drove
your mom like you drove your mom
everywhere
um she made a decision
okay
i'm stuck
so here's the thing so now my mom no
longer can make decisions for herself
right she's in a
a rehab facility
okay
um and her dementia is progressing
um she hasn't been able to make
so what can i rosalie what can i help
you with
she can't make decisions and choices are
you are you struggling with whether to
tell your brother
yes
okay all right
um
you've mentioned this a bunch so just
give me a yes or no answer
um you've mentioned this you spoke
around it a lot so i just want to poke
right in the middle of it
all right did you play a role in
convincing your mom that you should have
part of the house too because of all the
work you've done
absolutely not okay you are talking
about it as though you have some deep
guilt about it as though you played a
role in taking something from your
brother and if you did not i want to
encourage you to set that brick of guilt
down and never pick it up again
your mom made a grown-up decision with
her grown-up money
and then she unfortunately for you and i
don't ever like to talk bad about
somebody's mom but she did you wrong on
this one she stuck you in the middle of
it and said you be the person
that holds my lack of integrity
and i hate that she did that to you
but she did and she i'm more um
i'm duty i don't have guilt but i i'm
kind of duty bound to do what my mom
wants me to do you do but you also feel
sick to your stomach over it because
you're lying to your brother i do yes i
do yes thank you and so at some point
your duty to uphold someone's lack of
integrity is gonna smack into your
integris heart and your relationship
your honest relationship with your
brother
i agree and so i think um
uh if i'm you does your brother know
about your cancer
yes okay yes um and how is your cancer
by the way you you good
i am good
i'm good i'm i'm uh wonderful my my
surgery went well excellent it's so good
so i'm also told not to take care of my
mom anymore for
for six months to a year because of the
extent of my surgery that i can't lift
that kind of stuff so sure it's all good
i'm unable at this time to take care of
my mom
that's that's you've done
great stuff and she's in a home now
where she's getting the rehab care and
the in the daily care that she needs
which is awesome
so if i'm you
i would not it's not something you have
to do today or in two weeks or in five
months
i would call a sister with i mean a
meeting with all of your siblings
and just say i want to go over both
mom's stuff
and my stuff
and in that meeting
say
y'all don't know this but mom changed
some stuff in the will
um years ago
and
i just met with her attorney i'm gonna
roll all this out to everybody so we're
all on the same page
and let it just have you have to just
have a grown-up conversation here's what
you don't want to have happen
you don't want your brother
on one weekend to lose his mother if
when she finally passes away
and then also find out that his sister
has been lying to him for however many
years
and also lose a couple hundred thousand
dollars in assets in the same weekend
that's devastating
i agree right
so i don't
feel i stole anything but you absolutely
did not you didn't you didn't steal
anything but in his head
mom told him
this house goes to you
right and
so he exhaled and said great
then she changed it on him and didn't
have the courage to tell him because she
wanted him to still think it was his act
like it was his take care of it like it
was his
all the while knowing yeah it's not
really yours
right
and she put it on you
she put it on you to carry that around
agree that i agree with and that's the
part that's going to haunt you okay
that's going to haunt you and haunt you
and haunt you so
as the i mean
you're the are you the executor of this
estate i'm assuming
um no i'm not good god almighty who's
the executor
my brother
oh geez louise
well this ought to be fun so you can't
even go to the lawyer and get it he's
got to go get it huh
correct um actually it's a trust and
we're actually all on the trust i mean
we're all
i'm the medical executor my brother's
financial executor okay um
so how about this to answer your
ultimate question
um in this situation
um yes i think your brother has a right
to know
um
i don't know that it will be
it might be a shape-shifter moment for
your family it might not be
um since he's the executor of the will
it might be important to say hey mom
told me that like years ago she went and
changed some stuff in the will
that she split the house among several
of us like
i think you should go check on that
stuff as the executor of her estate as
we get here in the last year or two of
her life um go check on that um and as
an executor he can go do that
um that's what i would do if you were
the executor and could walk and i guess
if you're on the trust but i mean again
why would you be dinking around in the
trust if you didn't have something to do
with how it got changed and manipulated
so the whole thing sounds messy and the
whole thing i wish your mom had not have
put you in this situation
um
it wasn't an integral thing for her to
do she should have called all the kids
together and said hey i'm making a
couple of changes i decided to split the
house up among everybody just putting
the money up among everybody but instead
she
and again she can do whatever she wants
with her money
but when you do that behind somebody's
back i think the right thing to do is to
tell them by the way i've taken you out
of this
i'm sorry you're in that situation i
just think honesty in these situations
is the best and it's gonna cause
problems but hear me say the problems
have already been cast right that that
that roll of the dice has already been
thrown um it's just gonna be when you
all decide to look at the numbers that
rolled up and anytime i see something
coming down the road kicking the can is
never helpful and
i'd lean into that as soon as you can i
think your brother deserves that